no nome a trajano há cinco anos atrás eu
estava num momento bem interessante eu
era empresário e estava me destacando na
área da construção civil estava com 23
funcionários registrados alguns
contratos fechados
estava passando por um turbilhão de
informações até um certo dia eu ia pra
minha casa descansar e acordava outro
dia sem enxergar com o olho esquerdo e
me tratando com vários especialistas a
onde morava aí na capital do estado
após algum tempo sem resultado do olho
esquerdo acabei perdendo o olho direito
não tive naquele momento e não tenho nem
até hoje nenhum diagnóstico
aí eu me peguei a pensar é o ponto final
como que vai ser o arcar com as
responsabilidades com os novos
funcionários como vai ser o dia a dia
com a minha família ou no círculo de
amigos na sociedade como um todo mas não
precisava ser um ponto final poderia ser
uma vírgula um ponto e vindo até mesmo
reticências
foi onde eu conheci a instituição em que
eu freqüento e lá são desenvolvidas
diversas atividades voltadas para as
pessoas com deficiência visual braille
soroban a avaaz dança musicalização
orientação e mobilidade e o que me
resgatou
todo esse sentimento de não conseguir
que eu não poderia o esporte adaptado e
após cinco meses de treino
eu fui para minha primeira competição no
rio de janeiro
lá eu pude estar com diversos para
atletas até alguns que tiveram nas
paraolimpíadas anteriores e voltei de lá
com um terceiro lugar no dardo
lançamento do dardo e foi aí que eu
entendi que de 8 a 80 não é apenas
colocar 10 do lado do 8 existe mais
setenta e duas etapas
a gente tem que acreditar
a gente tem que ter fé e fé ela não está
direcionada somente a uma religião uma
criança mas acreditar em algo maior ter
fé acreditar em você eu acredito em mim
tenho femme esse ano 2019 eu participei
participei de algumas competições
primeira etapa regional do brasileiro
foi campeão do dardo primeiro lugar com
20 e 28 metros e 30 para já
campeão do dardo com 28 metros e 70 com
quebra de recorde
campeão paranaense do dardo 28 metros e
campeão do peso 9 metros e 7 este ano
foram quatro ouros
basta acreditar a gente pode muito mais
está dentro da mente de cada um
a onde pode chegar
acessibilidade acessibilidade é a
qualidade do que se é acessível e de
fácil acesso
aquilo que é atingível substantivo
feminino relacionado à facilidade de
aproximação no trato na aquisição
acessibilidade é o que nos leva para
mais perto da sociedade
todos os dias o que faz nós nos sentimos
livres que nos dar o direito de ir e vir
todos os dias
no momento em que queremos e acontece
algumas dia diariamente acontece muitas
coisas assim que nos fazem refletir como
podemos e como devemos eu geralmente
quando eu saio pra em algum lugar o
tento ser o mais importante independente
possível porque eu não sei quando vai
estar alguém ou alguém poderá e comigo
então eu tenho que ser independente e no
dia a dia acontece algumas situações
inusitadas
é eu na minha cidade atravessando o
calçadão
atravessei a primeira rua aí tava bem
parado movimento travesseiros chegado
através atravessei a segunda rua
sossegada chegou na terceira rua não
conseguia atravessar muito carro muito
barulho e complicado
pensei alto naquele momento bem que
podiam alguém ajudar o segue a
atravessar a rua
não devia ter falado
deixe que eu ajudo você atravessar a rua
devia ter uns três metros de altura o
rapaz então a dificuldade existe mas só
depende da gente ir em frente
as tecnologias nos levam para mais perto
do trabalho do estudo é eu tenho redes
sociais eu estudo através do notebook é
uma dificuldade a mais mas eu sei que eu
posso eu sei que eu consigo e eu sou
estudante na área de administração e eu
preciso muito da tecnologia e ela liga a
gente lugar a outra com a facilidade de
acesso
rápido então eu uso o celular
no meu caso celular nem vocês têm o
celular deus é goulart
sou cego nem e quitado
eu procuro usar o meu favor num gosto de
ser assim nenhum momento refém nessa
tecnologia tudo que é em excesso faz mal
muito mal
já teve algum tempo de eu querer a todo
momento ele está olhando facebook nessa
batizá pi e sms
eu faço todas essas atividades no
celular mesmo existe um aplicativo ele
conversa e tudo em vós
então todos os aplicativos todos os os
dados mesmo que tem no celular e através
do aplicativo que vai convertendo em vós
mas nos dados facilidade pra pra
conseguir ter acesso a todo
eu tenho um dia a dia bem agitada
eu acordo por volta das 6 horas da manhã
tudo um pouco
saiu de casa por volta das 17 20
bom para a instituição onde eu faço
essas atividades e treinos práticos
coordenativa do esporte
vou para a academia depois volto para
casa e saio geralmente por volta de 5 m
para ir à faculdade chegou por volta de
23 horas e 30 minutos
eu moro sozinho todas as atividades na
minha casa como conservação de vestuário
tudo eu faço sozinho alimentação e essa
rotina diária sair voltar a sair voltar
é fácil pra quem tem o motorista
particular
não é o meu caso é transporte público
eu vou com freqüência ao mercado sozinho
é complicado é muitas vezes você vai
errar o caminho mas a tua persistência
vai fazer você chegar onde você quer
eu há 16 anos atrás
jamais pensei em voltar a estudar jamais
pensei que um dia eu seria capaz de
estar dentro de uma faculdade eu não
tinha nem o ensino fundamental completo
eu demorei para entender que eu
precisava estudar eu pensava comigo não
sou empresário
eu vou me destacar e por que eu vou
estudar porque eu vou perder meu tempo
mas deveria ter pensado melhor antes de
ter pulado um muro 16 anos embora e não
voltado mais precisava
a vida me mostrar esse caminho
ele tem que ser respeitado todas as
etapas
então esse ano iniciei na faculdade de
administração e eu sei que eu vou
conseguir terminar é um e quem sabe
fazer uma pós o céu é o limite
só depende da gente acreditar que
consegue que vai chegar
eu você deve estar se perguntando qual
que é o sonho de uma pessoa com
deficiência
e por outro lado outros deve estar
respondendo já deve ser enxergada deve
ser esse o sonho dele
será que é sinceramente
digo pra vocês que meu sonho hoje não é
voltar a enxergar até mesmo porque
eu vivi uma vida muito hipócrita
hipócrita
eu vivia era muito mediano eu queria
saber de trabalhar só vivia pra isso
hoje meu sonho
sinceramente chegaram para a fama
paraolimpíada
como eu falei seria hipocrisia da minha
parte falar que não quer enxergar
sim eu quero se fosse pra mim enxergar e
viver a vida que eu tenho hoje
depois desses cinco anos hoje eu sou
feliz
hoje eu tenho uma vida que eu sempre
quis ter
mas eu tive que ter um beliscão da vida
antes disso a entender e eu sei que eu
vou conseguir chegar onde eu quero não
existe objetivo alcançado sem obstáculos
quebrados
eu vou deixar aqui um abraço a todos e
um agradecimento a todos pela atenção e
uma pergunta o que vocês querem ser
amanhã anões mundo de gigantes
o gigante em um mundo de anões essa
pergunta muito obrigado